scoff Butterworth's you have been
playing homefront the revolution game
that has had a colorful development
history I think it's easy to say it's
finally out of debt today yes and we
have a review and progress up on the
site full review of be going live
tomorrow March cross time yeah what do
you think of it just right off the bat
how good is homefront it's not great I
mean I've been seeing some other scores
go up and and my score will likely be in
line with those scores if people have
been paying attention it's been getting
a lot of fives and sixes a few 7s Jim
sterling really hated it right yep which
seems kind of unwarranted I mean he gave
the game a 1 and it's it's not a 1 it's
not great but I did I managed to have
quite a bit of fun playing the game
actually but I had to overlook a lot of
flaws in order to do it and like yeah
there's that game it just has a lot of
problems I think you go let's let's
first of all talk about I guess maybe
this is unfair I mean you can see it in
the footage right now so you sit next to
Peter and Peter was playing quake 3
which is in glorious 60 frames a second
and what I'm saying dude sorry - what
did I say quick 3 is it gosh no you were
not playing quick Jesus this is I just
want to do quake you're playing do when
it was like looking super buttery and
speaking of butter Scott Butterworth
next to him you're playing you're
playing homefront on it look man it
looked super spotty yeah it's right for
me it's super choppy also like a you
tell me not to make stupid jokes yeah
but I was accidental I'm so sorry
I think I may be influencing negative
way but yeah the frame weighted frame
rate is just one of several technical
problems and yeah across all three
platforms Rin have now played the game
on all three platforms it is choppy
pretty much throughout there are moments
when it's fine but there are also
moments when it slows just like a total
sputter like late in the game there are
some missions where there's a bunch of
vehicles and a ton of enemies and all
that is enough to make the game just
slow to a crawl it's crazy but even in
just sort of like regular
minute-to-minute action you know nothing
super crazy even then it's choppy and
unpredictable and so in terms of
performance obviously not great what
else you sort of alluding to in relation
to technical issues I mean there are
rough edges basically everywhere you
look in this game no matter
what you're playing you're gonna find
something weird like a enemies that just
stand there instead of fighting back
that's a weird one like trying to hide
from enemies and having n being spotted
through a wall small moments of like
there's a clip in our review in progress
video or you see my hand clip through a
door as I push it open that happens
literally every time in that particular
animation on ps4 I notice it doesn't
happen on Xbox and PC for whatever
reason they're the best versions to play
about they have their own problems man
like in all of them a stutter anytime in
Auto the game of auto saves like it's
again it's worse on ps4 it'll the game
will seriously just freeze for two
seconds as it auto saves and starfrit
item every time Wow yeah it's less
noticeable on Xbox and PC but it still
happens and it's like guys this is kind
of not acceptable oh I mean the game
auto-saves every couple minutes and for
the you know it really kind of pulls you
out of the experience but it just kind
of everything stops the game literally
freezes that's just a bit much yeah I
was put the word out for some for
questions over twitter clockwork Ian
asks how does homefront open world is
distinguish itself from other FPS
open-world games sure yeah so happy to
talk about the structure but to answer
that question directly it kind of
doesn't I mean had the technical issues
not been present and had there been some
thoughtful editing where they had you
know excluded parts where it kind of
drags or excluded mechanics don't work
as well it could have been a really
solid game not a great game not a really
like inspired or groundbreaking game but
a really just fun open-world shooter hmm
but like I said it's not groundbreaking
and those technical issues are there so
the way the game is structured is it's
pretty basic there are eight different
sections each of the sections is open
but you can't kind of walk from one end
to the other like you can in a Fallout
game okay so each area exists on its own
and they are relatively large and you
can't explore them freely but you have
to hop between them over the course of
the campaign which directs you through
them oh sorry if they're almost like
linear sort of like open little smaller
open worlds yeah yeah yeah and they are
all like if you look at the world map
you can kind of see how they're
connected but isn't it a loading screen
or something or is it all it's all set
in Philadelphia so it's I mean in which
doesn't resemble any part of
Philadelphia that I've ever visited or
seen but okay fine there are like
particular landmarks that are borrowed
is that Bruce Springsteen song playing
over the top constantly I I wish there
were some Bruce Springsteen the sound is
actually one of the weirder parts of the
game where like there will be music
playing when there's nothing happening
it'll be like just really tense music it
must be like cuddling there's somebody
about to attack me like I don't what why
is this happening and I'm just kind of
like paranoid and it I can't tell if
it's a bug or just a weird design choice
like that's that's like I've been living
my life when you probably had the same
thing over the weekend with doom or
whenever the music is hyped I'm like on
edge completely yeah like there's one
more of these [ __ ] around here
somewhere yeah we've been conditioned
like that's how games work and movies
and everything yeah it's it's a very
subtle like hey like you should be
paying attention something's going to
try to kill you so it's weird when
nothing tries to kill you and the music
implies otherwise what the hell so what
about the sort of general action there's
anything that distinguishes it outside
of it's solid it's fine the shooting
mechanics the stealth doesn't work quite
as well so it's really kind of a shooter
stealth game you can approach it either
way but right the stealth is super
inconsistent like there were times when
I was spotted and I didn't understand
why and there were times when I would
see someone's awareness meter starting
to fill and I would just sprint in the
opposite direction and that was fine for
some reason you think that that would
cause their meter to feel faster because
this crazy person is now sprinting in
the other direction but it didn't seem
to make a difference but the shooting is
actually pretty fun it feels a lot like
a Far Cry game which makes sense given
that this is a CryEngine games right
yeah I mean you have kind of multiple
weapons you can add attachments on the
Flies all that kind of stuff so there's
nothing particularly distinctive about
it or really memorable about the
moment-to-moment shooting but it can be
it can be fun it can get really frantic
and chaotic the enemies are not bullet
sponges which is really nice but neither
are you so you kind of have to be
careful and thoughtful and there's
actually like small platforming moments
as well where you have to get to like a
transceiver on top of a building you do
need to find your way up there's some
certain moments like that that remind me
of like dying light for example right so
that actually helps to break up the the
gameplay and add some another kind of
dimension so again like I have fun in a
lot of those moments it's just that
there's so much other stuff to deal with
and in the meantime then really pulls
the experience down
it's a shame yeah I guess last point on
this there is some sort of co-op stuff
going on here as well how does that play
out yeah so there is a compared to
completely separate components in this
game there is the single-player campaign
which is actually like remarkably long
it's a very substantial campaign and
this is one of the sort of best
attributes of the game that there is a
really long and substantial and varied
campaign it's probably a good 20 20
hours for most planets if you want to
you if you do everything you can easily
extend that to like 25 if you just rush
through you can probably do it in 15 but
it's far more substantial than the first
Homefront game but in addition to that
there is a co-op campaign which is six
missions that are kind of sort of
designed to be replace or well you would
there's nothing encouraging you to do
that other than the sort of the the
selectable difficulty level but each of
those can be completed in like 10 to 15
minutes so 6 missions is not a lot and
there's a really basic unlock system but
it's all done through loot crate's so
you can't actually pick what you're
unlocking you just have to hope you get
what you're what you want it's it I'm
not super impressed I don't I don't feel
like it really adds much to the
experience to be completely honest but
again it's a totally separate component
so if you're interested you think and
get something out of it great go play it
if not it's just kind of there and I
don't know
ya know what else is just kind of there
that's that timesplitters - yeah that's
that's a real thing there's an easter
egg in the game which they've actually I
guess so this is I think I believe
public knowledge but I actually stumbled
onto this without knowing that yeah
there's one section late in the game
where you're like in a prison and you go
up to one of these like abandoned floors
and you find an old arcade cabinet and
if you approach it it's like hit button
to play like okay and so I did and it
turns out that it's like three levels
from timesplitters lives it up yep yeah
and it plays the game's opening cutscene
and you can play those missions and yeah
right is this like the whatever without
getting into spoilers about other games
this seems to be the new thing and video
games now is that you just throw another
video game inside we're at that point
where that that's a thing that gue might
sense yeah I think we're three for three
in a week I think the original didn't
the original black ops have like Zork or
something like it had no could of I
don't remember there was some like it's
full game hidden away and I think that
was the first time I remember finding a
complete game within another game I bet
it is
so been a complete movie remember the
darkness had to kill a mockingbirds and
oh it did yeah you know you sit down
with your girlfriends like Jackie sits
down with his girlfriends yeah that to
kill a mockingbirds
plays on a television it's the whole
movie well you can literally watch like
Atticus Finch chat for like two hours
that's really crazy pretty weird my
favorite inclusion would be in blades of
steel on the nes where between periods I
think it was every period maybe it
wasn't everyone you could play Gradius
oh really shooter good to kill the time
and until you died you would yeah and
that loading screen patent is now gone
so maybe we'll see more that sort of
stuff we're Ridge Racer and Galaxia I
think I was was in that one oh
interestingly we're seeing fewer and
fewer loading screens there are plenty
in homefront but games like you know
fallout or which are you know basically
limited themselves Shane we're not gonna
get you know too many loading game
loading screen games maybe a lot of the
people in the chat were noticing the
little autosave pauses that were
happening in our gameplay oh yeah what's
funny is often the audio will continue
on so the game itself is frozen soggy
stream of of sports games yeah so I hope
that that registers for people watching
our footage of it it's not like the
video there watching had an encoding
problem or their internet is faltering
that's what the game actually looks like
when you're playing it the action just
stops for seriously a full two seconds
which I mean I hope the RZA doesn't
sound like a lot but when you're playing
and just all of a sudden everything
freezes yeah it's enough to be like
what's going on and okay there it goes
it's it's weird man I'm not um alright
why don't we see the full review for
homefront the revolution on games will
be up tomorrow now that I've played all
three versions of the game which as I
mentioned was not the most fun I mean I
don't I don't want to completely crap
all over the game it does some cool
things I had some fun playing it it's
it's a shame that it's kind of a mess
but yeah I mean I
I don't know